it's been four years and 700 shows of
harry potter laughs our friends from the
potter potter are back as they give us
or as they gear up to celebrate the
show's upcoming milestones
congratulations guys thank you
i'm excited so it's been 15 years of
this show
right no no not in vegas not in vegas
but all over the world exactly yeah so
we're actually we're celebrating our
four-year anniversary wow
in vegas yeah four years at valleys
that's amazing that's i mean how's it
feel
you know you guys get to just do harry
potter jokes and laughs and kind of you
know just do your passion for your for
your work it's very rare that you find a
job where you want people to laugh at
you yeah
like we really want that right right no
that's incredible and so for the
celebration you know when exactly is the
anniversary and and how what are you
guys doing what's the what's the party
plan
well i'm expecting a cake balloons
you're expecting yeah i'm expecting a
purse
on it yeah my dressing room i want to be
covered with everything from party city
other stores are available
shameless plug they must be sponsored
yeah right yeah that's where we get a
lot of props exactly exactly exactly now
um you're extending also in celebration
the show till january yeah for january
2023 very very lucky for that yeah more
chance to make people laugh it's great
so what should we expect is there
anything new you're adding to the show
in the extension
we're talking about it we're talking
about a couple things we play live gamer
quidditch okay during the show uh right
in the middle what and uh we're talking
about tweaking a couple of things okay
okay just to freshen up a little bit
but um i don't know we're just so
blessed to keep doing our show every day
yeah and we'll change it when people
stop laughing
like maybe myself who
i respect harry potter and the movies
but i'm not a super fan but i'm i'm told
that i would still enjoy the show
absolutely you don't you don't have to
be a harry potter nerd right you don't
even have to really have read the books
that's the beauty of our show yes
you'll come in we'll do the work for you
okay you watch you listen we'll tell you
what's going on harry potter world it's
fine spark no it's on stage
that is my kind of show that's my
accomplishment my kind of lesson okay so
how can people come see the show just
give everybody a rundown where he can
catch us at valleys with the magic attic
we do shows daily uh we have tuesday uh
2 pm excuse me of uh yeah tuesday to pay
2 pm matinees and matinees over the
weekend as well we're up at the magic
attic yeah so kid friendly bring your
kids come out 2pm come after church on
sunday we'll be there it'll be fine all
right well congratulations on the
anniversary and all of the success
continued success
appreciate it thanks for having us thank
you okay jc outstanding